foreign
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
at Facebook and uncensored tonight
should fat people get free seats on
airplanes should teachers and girls
schools apologize for saying good
afternoon girls to the girls or have we
perhaps reached the peak of woke
Insanity in the age of massive
self-entitlement we'll debate that
also tonight released from a Romanian
jail was still under house arrest what
next for the world's most controversial
man right now Andrew Tate his lawyer
joins me live
because Bill Maher is one of the
funniest and most servic commentators in
the United States it does the
exclusively it taught Trump Biden
canceled culture and the Royals
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored well
good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan on Center Welcome to our
our lovely new studio here at the news
UK Mothership uh in London Bridge we've
left Ealing in West London no tears no
flowers uh and we're here where it all
happens uh so what have I missed I've
been in Los Angeles trying to lie under
palm trees with Stormy Daniels
um what I missed was this the age of
entitlement was a period of history when
the world's biggest brains began to
reject Superstition for logic and reason
we've now reached the age of entitlement
in which the world's biggest brains defy
logic and behave very unreasonably take
the children at a prestigious Girls
School part of the independent girls Day
School trust who staged a placard waving
protest against a teacher who said good
afternoon girls
that teacher was then forced to issue a
groveling apology according to the
interviews you gave to the male or
Sunday the weekend apparently under
threat of disciplinary action because
the girls who remember are attending a
girls school objected to being called
girls well I guess some of them they
want to become Boys in which case they
should maybe be at a boys school
they're not entitled to undermine the
authority of the teachers in the school
to pursue their own social causes
and take this plus-sized influencer
no one should have to endure the
discomfort embarrassment and
discrimination that often comes with
being a plus-sized passenger trying to
navigate air travel by signing this
petition you can help us demand that
Airlines take concrete steps to make air
travel more inclusive and accommodating
for all passengers whether you're plus
size or not everybody deserves to be
treated with dignity and respect when
they fly let's work together to make
sure that the travel industry serves
everyone not just a select few
well Jaylene Cheney made Global
headlines this weekend after claiming
fat people are entitled to extra seats
on planes because they're so fat
she said all plus-sized passengers
should be provided with an extra free
seat or even two or three seats
depending on their size to accommodate
their needs and ensure their comfort
during the flight
well look uh Jaylene you can have your
extra seat and have 10 extra seats
you've got to pay for them
why should you be entitled to special
treatment raising the cost of travel for
everybody else because you're obese
maximum self-entitlement zero
self-accountability
so you've invited me to speak here and
I'm being hackled Non-Stop and I'm just
asking for an administrator
[Music]
if you want another place of ideas you
have gotten what you wanted
those are students at Stanford
University one of the top universities
in the world
where students are so high on the fumes
of their own self-importance they're
felt entitled to Heckle a visiting judge
because they didn't like his politics
the scourge of Limitless entitlement
takes us down Avenues of Limitless
Insanity it means we have honest jobs we
can't fill but a generation of waste
rules you want to be paid for posting
photographs of their lunch at least to
the ludicrous race-baiting idea that
every white person should pay
compensation to every black person
because of the evils of History it means
we give out medals to kids who come last
to because they tried and the parents of
those children then demand they're
awarded better grades literally just
because they're paid to be there
unfortunately the cost of living crisis
as a servant of these people who think
the world owes them a favor but
fortunately the rest of us are also
entitled to call them out for it well
joining me now is the associated sort of
Daily Mirror Kevin McGuire and talk to
the contributor Esther crackhead I think
I'm not sure but I think I might have
started that in my jet lagged Haze Kevin
was slightly wrong analogy I said the
age of entitlement twice of course I was
meant to say the Age of Enlightenment
has now become the age of entitlement
how's he got like this yeah I'm not sure
entirely has no peers I think we make
progress because one Generation
Challenges the the one ahead of them
that's that's how it is now they don't
always get it right but I'm with those
girls in that school they challenge the
teacher she lost the classroom they
wanted they wanted the teacher to
address I mean they're at a good school
Kevin but what literally literally their
parents have said we want to send our
little girl to a girls school which is
called a girls school yeah and then when
a teacher has the audacity to call them
girls they go nuts and the teacher then
eventually has to leave because they
challenge the teacher the teacher stands
on her Authority and says now I'm doing
it my way if that teacher had spoken to
them had a child
look one of them wasn't identifying as a
girl I just don't see what the big
problem is
if you don't here's what the problem is
if you don't identify as a girl don't go
to a bloody girls school Esther have I
got nuts well what if what if one of
them identified as a tree would you say
hello hello I don't know
I mean before I went away I identified I
went to a girl identified as a black
lesbian yeah your cackle went round the
world no set her off again but this is
the problem if anyone can identifies
anything they like then this Insanity
just goes everywhere oh of course but I
think the the bigger message that's
being sent out here is that the children
are ruling the classrooms which should
never be the case and there's no point
of them going to school because part of
going to school is learning discipline
and respectful Authority how can you
possibly bully a teacher into
apologizing for calling you a girl I'm a
great believer in good discipline in
schools but that does not
it's to launch some kind of protest it's
how you set the rules and how you then
govern that school
you don't even you don't believe this I
do no you I do you don't think a bunch
of girls and a girls should have the
right to drive a teacher I'm sorry the
teacher has gone but I don't believe the
teachers handled it as well as they she
said good afternoon girls and if it's
then Challenge and the kids are
explaining why they think they shouldn't
be distressed
do not see what the problem is this is
not the same as putting a biological man
who is a rapist and only aware a man can
in a Scottish prison it's not that case
and what happens
I can't do any more of that one this
just drive me too man can we at least
agree about free seats for fat flies
Esther the idea that the more obese you
get the fatter you become the more free
seats you're entitled to on a plane oh
it's ridiculous well I mean the the lady
in the video who was saying it she was
probably the size of the plane that she
wanted to fly look the reality is we've
always seen you know debates online
about whether you know if you need a
seatbelt extension you should really buy
two seats because you're spilling over
and see the other person's person seat
and airplanes are designed to basically
continue like sardines right so the idea
that someone else should pay for the
fact that she's obese is quite frankly
ludicrous well the only thing more
annoying anything more annoying than
influences are than just stop oil
protesters so tonight uh one of them has
jumped on this snooker table during a
live match between Robert milkens and
Joe Perry and emptied a bag of orange
powder here we go
that's really really gonna make me want
to do more about saving the planet
actually what it wants me to do it makes
me want to remove the planet of certain
people led by that complete and utter
imbecile who's just wrecked everybody's
enjoyment at a snooker match I mean
Kevin what possible
possible purpose does this have other
than annoying everybody I'm not sure it
does look my heart might be with the
stop uh just stop while protesters but I
think my head says that will be
counterproductive of course that will
not help now again I believe in protest
I believe in people's right to protest
but you have to face the consequences
why do people like this get to get away
with such delinquency but the rest of us
have to follow the rules what if we all
started doing that what if I yeah what
if we what if we all started being
public nuisances for causes that we're
passionate about what I want everybody
to be an Arsenal fan especially in this
rather tense moment of the season and if
you're not I'm going to come around your
house jump on your snooker table and
spray it with orange paint because I
want something yeah right that's what it
boils down to yeah this is what I talk
about the age of entitlement they
pretend they want to save the planet
actually they want to make a name for
themselves doing this kind of thing as
we saw at the Grand National the weekend
with all the protesters there they just
want to ruin everybody's fun well yeah
of course and they're they're peddling
particularly in narratives that no one
else is buying because they don't make
sense right you don't get to do this and
stop bullying the public because we
don't agree with your tactics look like
I had a bet on the national I love horse
racing but those protesters also have a
point about the safety of that race when
three horses died this year four died
last year there is
statistics one of the horses died I
think on the on the First Fence which
suggests that it could have been the
turmoil and the late start that may have
caused that horse said that right so
maybe maybe these goons at the Grand
National actually facilitated the death
of one of those horses that is possible
that could be true right yeah that
cannot be ruled out no no you're
absolutely right and then again that can
be counter productive look if you're
gonna if you're going to protest you
want to win the audience they've lost it
I'm not sure they do um but this is the
thing I'm not we we keep talking about
how they're trying to win people over
and this is not the way to do it don't
glue yourself to the M25 for example I
don't think they want to win people over
I think it's just to construct their own
egos I totally agree I totally agree a
bunch of spoiled entitled little brats
who want to get in the papers and get on
TV and sadly we occasionally have to
give them what they want because these
are genuine news events they're wrecking
the Grand National they're wrecking the
snooker and they go home and they think
oh what a great day we fed all we've
done is ruined yeah but come on can we
can we acknowledge though that we are as
a you know people we're heating up the
planet that's creating destruction that
will result in people's dying so yeah
I'm against putting orange powder and
disrupting a snooker match but let's not
lose sight that people are dying
to get people to ignore that before we
finish I want to bring in someone who I
think is causing the uh the death of the
planet slowly Prince Harry
um so Camilla Parker Ball's done to a
well-sourced piece in the Sunday Times
it's apparently very hurt by all the
stuff that Harry wrote about her in the
book uh saying that she was dangerous
had to rehabilitate Her Image blah blah
blah wicked stepmother
um I don't blame Jamila do you Western I
mean I just think of course and for this
guy to have the brass neck to now roll
up at the at the coronation
of the head of a institution he's just
spent the last two three years
absolutely burying calling a bunch of
callous races I think is is outrageous
and for Paul Camilla who's also going to
be crowned of course along with Charles
for her to have to see him coming in
after calling it a wicked dangerous
stepmother I mean yeah it should be for
the last first of all of Harry's
whinging about you know the invasions of
privacy and how he was painted as a
villain I never want to hear him talk
about privacy again ever ever
as long as he lives yep I never want to
hear the word privacy come out of his
entitled talk about entitlement entitled
hypocritical Gob ever Kevin Am I Wrong
Camilla has been has been villainized
for for decades so she's used to this
but Camilla is the very best of rules
you know why never explain never
complain suck it up do your juice and
that's why people now like Camilla and
when you are a hypocritical rap bag the
public soon go off you as he's now
finding out let's not lose sight that
his dad Harry's dad was cheating with
Camilla yeah and Harry's mother
you can see from his point of view yeah
the stepmother did clear part in the
brick and he's nearly 40 years old
enough of that she has to also that
knowledge all right he's hurt and he's
pinned you know what I don't care how
hurt he is I'm bored with him I'm sick
of the pair of them stay in California
do your stuff take the titles away and
don't turn up at the Royal events just
to keep your little Royal fleecing going
that's all it's about
total hypocrisy thank you Pat great to
be back
we got through a lot of stuff there well
I'm sensitive next tonight Andrew Tate's
lawyer live on what is going on
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel nobody
is uh every little helps for God's sake
is nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at 7
p.m join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
I like this new fancy Studio a director
going crazy there with his little
Corridor action I like it well welcome
back to Piers Morgan nonsense and same
show just a slightly Jazzy a little
setup well he's the most controversial
man on the planet president company
accepted social media influencer Andrew
Tate the former professional kickboxer
and his brother have been locked up for
three months in a Romanian jail over
allegations of human trafficking and
rape they've not been charged they've
now been released on house arrest they
remain under investigation we're
arriving home early this month this is
what Andrew Tate had to say
well I've been in one room since last
year so uh it's a little bit emotional I
want to give respect firstly to the
judges who hurt us today because they
were very attentive and they listened to
us and and they let us freeze I I truly
believe that Justice will be served in
the end there is zero percent chance of
me being found guilty of something I
have not done
so joining us now is Andrew Tate's
lawyer Tina Tina thank you very much
indeed for joining us again on Piers
Morgan and sentencing where are we with
this case because it does seem very
strange that there is still no sign of
any charges or of them being released
hi Pierce we're certainly a lot better
off today than the last time I was on
your show as you recall back then the
tape brothers were still detained in a
Romanian jail cell now they have been
released on house arrest so relative to
that you know they're doing much better
now and we've taken a big step in the
right direction however this month
actually marks the one year since this
investigation first began and the fact
that they're still on house arrest and
the fact that they're restraint and
their Liberty their Liberty is still
restrained and they're not free to move
about the way anybody else would while
this very prolonged investigation
continues
is obviously substantially troubling and
frustrating to them so even though a few
weeks ago we took a big step in the
right direction we're still not all the
way there and we are we're looking
forward to the day that the Romanian
authorities decide that they won't be uh
that they conclude the investigation and
decide that they won't be seeking an
indictment in this case what are the
rules of the house race only asked
because before I came on air I noticed
that Justin Tate uh tweeted me several
times about tonight's show actually
um is that him are they allowed to tweet
personally the the two brothers
they are the only real restrictions that
they have other than the fact that
they're confined to their house is that
they can't communicate with either the
two other women who also like them or on
house arrest who are being investigated
alongside them in this matter and any
other Witnesses who have been mentioned
in the file beyond that there are no
other restrictions as far as
communication with friends or family or
having visitors as well as social media
activity there's obviously been an
enormous amount of global coverage of
this
um and obviously they remain innocent
until Aretha ever charged or proven
guilty how are they actually doing
themselves I mean it's a weird condition
to to be living under house arrest
it is again it's it's relative to where
they were a few weeks ago they are doing
much better of course
um however the three months in jail
certainly took a toll on them and I know
Andrew has told me he right now has a
lot of trouble sleeping he can't sleep
for more than two hours a night and you
know it really took a toll so they're
struggling with the process on what
they've been through but they are now
focused mostly on just regaining they
believe a strong uh strong body is a
strong mind they're back to their
training and fitness and health and
focusing on those things and trusting
their attorneys in the process to play
out and for them to eventually clear
their names the court of public opinion
has been depending on what you read uh
particularly on social media but
obviously they have this huge platform
each of them it's either been brutally
Savaged against them pre-judging
everything and assuming their guilt or
it's being the complete opposite that
they are the victim terms of a shocking
miscarriage of Justice can they get any
kind of fair trial even if it was to
come to that given the enormous amount
of coverage
while we're certainly hoping it doesn't
come to that but yes all of those things
that you said really do jeopardize
somebody in a case like this always
these high-profile cases We Believe
oftentimes the defendant can't get a fur
trial because there is such
unfortunately a presumption of guilt in
these types of cases there is a lot of
misinformation spread prior to the case
actually being heard and opinions are
formed and a lot of times again it's not
based on the actual evidence so I think
it is very challenging to have a fair
trial under circumstances such as such
as the tape brother case here however
again we are optimistic that the
evidence is not going to support an
indictment and that it won't come to
that if it does go to trial would it be
a jury trial or just a judge
a judge
the I think since we last spoke in the
last several weeks actually three
British women have come forward to see
they were abused and sexually assaulted
by Andrew Tate and a crowdfunding to sue
him for compensation they're all in
their 20s or early 30s they worked as
webcam models for Andrew they say in
Luton from 2013 onwards claim they were
abused poorly paid and threatened to
stop them going to the police what's
your response to that
well first to be clear there's no
there's no new lawsuit and there's
certainly these are not new allegations
these are old allegations from 2014 and
2015 that I would seriously you know I
think there's questions about the timing
and motivation as to why this is now
being brought up I certainly don't think
it's a coincidence that you know right
after they've been released on house
arrest that this has now again come up
but just to be clear what what this case
right now is it's three Anonymous women
who have not come forward with their
identities
are seeking crowd uh funding and they're
seeking I think 50 000 pounds to begin
with and I believe they've raised at
this point a little bit over 8 000
pounds and this is so that they could
sue the Bro Sue Andrew Tate for
compensation so they're basically asking
the public to fund their efforts to get
money from Andrew Tate and what's
bizarre about this
um aside from the fact that these same
allegations were previously investigated
by the UK authorities who decided that
there was no evidence and it was not
sufficient to pursue charges against
Andrew Tate but putting that aside
what's strange to me as an attorney
certainly in my experience cases of this
type are often brought by attorneys on
what we call a contingency fee basis
which means that the attorney if they
believe in the Case Files the lawsuit
prosecutes it and then from the monies
that they recover for their client they
take a percentage of that so to me it's
very strange that instead of
pursuing the case like that which would
typically be done they're asking for the
public for donations to fund this
attempt for these Anonymous women again
to make money from Andrew Tate and I
think it's really important to remember
cases like Eleanor Williams which
recently I know got a lot of attention
and I saw your interview with one of the
men who uh Eleanor had falsely accused
and there are cases where women go to
crazy and extreme lengths I know in that
case she had created fake social media
profiles she had sent herself um you
know fake messages that were reported
initially to be evidence she went so far
as to purchase a hammer and to
self-inflict severe injuries just to
jump into it we're running out of time
that was an outrageous case and that she
was a total fantasist and a very evil
one at that I think look to be fair to
your clients they are innocent until
proven guilty they've not been charged
this has been going on for a year
they've been held in prison for month
after month after month they're now
effectively under a sort of Home prison
and you do think at some stage that out
of fairness and Justice they are either
going to be charged or released and
we'll see what happens but I think next
week you're expecting to get an update
right
we will get an update next week because
they can only extend this house arrest
for a total combined with the three
months that they already served it's a
total of six months in Romania so if
they seek an application it will be made
next week well hopefully we can talk to
you again after that development Tina
glandian thank you very much indeed
thank you pierce
well also said next uh tonight Superstar
U.S comedian and TV host Bill Maher one
of my favorite hosts on American TV sat
down me to talk Biden Trump canceled
culture wokery and yes the Royals
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with a people's Channel don't
worry every little helps for God's sake
is nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you passionate and always straight
to the point world-class broadcaster
Vanessa Felts is on talk TV every night
of the week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to Piers of organizing from
our spanking new Studios next tonight
Bill Maher is one of the most acerbic
and popular commentators on us
television for three decades he's
eviscerated politicians on the left and
the right with equal fervor unlike me is
a ferocious defender of free speech I
first appeared on his HBO show real time
on Friday night and things got rather
Heating and I took on democratic
congresswoman Katie Porter of women's
rights the clips went viral and
astonishingly the very liberal La crowd
well they rather audibly sided with me
I think that it should be up to sporting
bodies to make the decisions about who
what if she said that's actually wrong I
think that what she has done is try to
turn this we talked about people you
know becoming using things to kind of
get likes and get clicks that's not what
she's doing I mean I've got no truck
right against personally but all I've
seen her do is stand up for women's
rights to fairness and equality she
actually competed against Leah Thomas
and it was obviously unfair Leah Thomas
won one of the races in the NCAA
championships by 50 seconds against a
bunch of biological females who simply
couldn't keep up that cannot be right it
cannot be fair that is something no
we've just come off your own show uh how
do you feel when you come off doing a
show well we just came off yeah there
you go all this is gone the question is
how did we come off
um the audience is gone and it's just us
it's so intimate Pierce
um you know it's so funny
I don't sleep well on Friday night
because I'm a perfectionist and I'm
always turning the show over in my mind
all night long you know it's a live well
actually we were alive for 20 years I
think the last year since the pandemic
we tape a little earlier but we tape in
time we don't edit anything so it's
basically what happens what is what
happens you know so uh it can go 99
perfectly and I will obsess on the one
percent
I'm sorry
um I have a an ongoing theory that the
world has gone nuts but what I can't
work out is whether it's just because
we're aware of more stuff which is nuts
than we ever used to be or do you
actually feel oh yeah that it is going
nuts yes absolutely it is going nuts I
mean we sort of touched it out on the
show tonight when I was talking about
norms and the attitude I think of the
conservative people in this country
about
what's what disturbs them on the left I
would think it's I would say it's The
Fringe of the left but you know the
problem with the left is that the people
in the center who don't even believe
what The Fringe are believing don't
stand up to them they don't shout them
down publicly so it just becomes it's
very bad for Democrats which I don't
think is a good thing I mostly vote for
Democrats I can't remember the last time
I voted for a republican but the Norms
that Trump trounced on
that's a very valid point one I've made
a million times and we all saw it in
plain sight I mean Norms of the law and
democracy and answering subpoenas and
respecting elections and not trying to
have a coup in America I mean it went
past Norms but their view is okay those
are terrible Norms perhaps to trample
but your Norms have to do with like life
itself right biological sex that's
exactly I got that debate tonight yeah
he's kind of baffling to me or actually
having to debate that's that is what
they're saying I've heard I've taught
I've talked to these people all the time
but because I'm out in the country all
the time and they're like you know we're
not all crazy we just don't we just
don't feel comfortable and I've said
this before I'll say it again a lot of
them say to me
what you don't get about us and Donald
Trump is we don't like him either we
just see him as a bulwark toward against
something that's even nuttier because as
we know in America people really don't
vote for who they like they vote for who
they hate the least right
um and where are you with free speech
now because it seems to me that as a
comedian and a host
comedy has never been under more attack
than it is now I mean literally physical
attacks yeah on comedians on stage to
try and suppress their right to tell
jokes what do you feel about that I
think that's exactly I never feel like
I'm about to be attacked on stage it
could happen tomorrow you know
um but I I that's not something that I
there's been a few instances the Dave
Chappelle won obviously the Will Smith I
mean these are outliers we're not really
attacked what we comedians are afraid of
is not being attacked physically on
stage we're afraid of being attacked on
Twitter being canceled yes that I mean I
grew up in the age of the comedy club
and there's comedy clubs are still out
there by the way but you could they were
a place as they say to be bad or a place
even if you weren't bad if you had
passed that point to try out new
materials have we lost the ability as a
society to accept being offended well of
course and that's part of it I mean
comedy has to find where the line is you
know oh you crossed the line well I'm
the guy who's I'm the like the the Mind
Seeker I'm out there with the bayonet
you know digging into the ground to see
where the minds are who decides once in
a while one's going to blow up in our
face some credit for being the guy out
there with the bayonet and who decides
the line
apparently teenagers who decide
everything in this country because I
feel like teenagers are the ones or
people with a teenage mentality uh
who are are the ones who fill social
media with condemnation because they
were raised wrong
with a sense of entitlement in a sense
that anything that causes the least
amount of discomfort cannot be tolerated
for even one second so when they scream
and cry nobody says anything that's my
point about where are the people to push
back what are the adults I don't think
most I don't think most of the Democrats
or most of the Liberals in this country
old school liberals like me are like
this kind of stuff but they don't shout
it down so if somebody does something
that's a little bit outside the lines
and there is a big complaint on social
media nobody stands up for them and the
problem is that nobody ever gets
canceled through being too woke so you
can say the craziest thing like men can
have babies
and then nobody even though people are
thinking well that's kind of nuts nobody
will say it they'll just fall in line uh
yeah yeah exactly that's what I've
always thought Mentor babies sure I saw
a dude who was glowing yesterday you
know I mean it's and that's the problem
and it's totally insane cowardice yes it
is it's moral cowardice isn't it but
it's an intellectual characters but it
also comes from a place of reality that
fear because they see people around them
literally getting canceled getting
shamed and abused and hounded out of
jobs and they think I don't want it to
happen to me I can't count the number of
stories I've either covered on the show
or just read about of professors at
colleges which are supposed to be the
bastions of free speech who said
something that was just an opinion one
guy that was different from America he
gave a lecture for 25 years about the
use of offensive language and then some
students complained about his use of
offensive language in the lecture about
offensive language and he had to lose
his job and at that point I just felt
that was Peak woke Insanity he literally
was lecturing about offensive language
and using offensive language to
illustrate it they they have no sense of
nuance they have no sense of context
they just know certain buzzwords where
certain concepts are out of limits off
limits and since social media is just a
bunch of Mean Girls It's not really
about making the world better it's not
really very often about social justice
it's about let's catch somebody at
something this is what's so obnoxious
about that side of things that just idea
of we're not really lifting people up
liberalism is about lifting people up
not catching and tolerating people it's
not about white self-loathing yes it's
about yes we have a horrible history in
this country let's make it right in the
ways that make sense it's not just about
catching people at stuff
where is America politically now do you
think
I think old school liberalism is the
center
certainly socially you know when I think
about things like pot legalization civil
rights
gay marriage that kind of stuff I mean
something like something over 90 percent
I think of white Americans want to live
in a diverse neighborhood this is a sea
change from where the where the world is
was when I was born
um gay marriage failed I think 35 times
in different states when it was on the
ballot on a Statewide level and if
something like four years later it was
the law of the land marijuana I never
thought I would see the day where I I
wasn't panicked when I was in an airport
because I had this much pot hidden in my
underwear
and now I can smoke it freely on my
podcast
I came out having had a great time bill
um so I I think that really is kind of
the center of the country old school
liberalism take a Victory lap you kind
of won on a lot of things but it's a
that's another funny pathology of
liberals they don't want to acknowledge
progress because they somehow feel like
if I acknowledge progress well then I'm
not as authentic a progressive it's
right in your name and that's what
you're selling progress well of course
on Donald Trump
all this legal Mayhem that's flying at
him does it actually Empower him does it
have the opposite effect perhaps to what
the Democrats would hope it would have
yes well that was the end of the show
tonight when I was talking about the
Stormy Daniels issue I mean it's always
going to strike people as sex it when
it's about getting a guy for sex I don't
think they should ever they should have
discouraged I guess Alvin Bray can do
what he wants but if I was the president
or somebody I would have discouraged him
quietly let's not do this one because
we're going to see Trump hauled into
court as we did and that's going to be
the big story and it's going to be just
high fives on MSNBC and look I was
thrilled it there's something cathartic
about seeing that because this guy has
done so much damage to this country as
well as so many individuals so to see
him hold into court feels good but now
when these real cases come up the ones
about asking for votes in Georgia
January 6th
um even the documents one I mean I just
think it the the power of it is going to
be diminished can he win again he can I
don't think he will but it doesn't
matter with him this is the point I've
been making since 2016. well you
predicted I did you said every year I
watched you and you'd say almost
everything he wouldn't accept it he will
never accept it and he didn't and the
problem with next time is he's done this
once and he saw what didn't work the
first time he has been working behind
the scenes to make sure that doesn't
happen again in other words next time he
calls up a republican Secretary of State
and says I need you to find 11 000 votes
is that Republican Secretary of State
going to be somebody who's there who
wasn't in 2016 who is there specifically
to do that so you know I I don't know
what's going to happen in 2024 my my
prediction would be it's Biden against
him again Biden wins again and he
doesn't accept it again is he I mean is
he I'll have to ask about buying because
I've heard you defend him about his
record in the the term I think he's been
actually better than people think which
is why he did better in the midtones
Than People expected but he's really
showing his ages two more years before
an election if he then does four more
he'd be 86. what you know does that
matter it doesn't matter to me I feel
like this is a Prejudice that this
country has this ageism it's a it's an
individual thing age some people are old
at 50. and some people are Young At 90.
Norman lears over a hundred I had dinner
with him recently with other people he
was as sharp as anybody at the table so
it doesn't matter and a president
doesn't have to be super energetic to
run for president takes a lot of benefit
to be president you're the Elder every
civilization seems to understood this
the Elder we go to you for advice and
wisdom hey Elder one who has seen it all
well what should we do about this
problem and then he has his minions go
ahead and you don't have to be and also
I just think it's a narrative that oh he
looks old he's he looks like the same
guy I've ever seen he's a little older
so he fell off his bike and you
mentioned Trump's fat ass even being on
a bike
really Biden did say another interesting
thing actually uh he said that yes he's
got more experience than anyone that's
ever become president and he said but
that gives me no excuses gives them the
wisdom but also no excuses I thought I
was quite an honest appraisal of what
all that experience gives him yeah I
just think people have look do I love
everything Biden has done no I don't I
think he caves into that super left side
a little too much I think they go to him
with that stuff and he goes I don't
understand it I can't be bothered with
it I have real matters to do if you want
to do this fine I'm not going to fight
you on it and you know is it as uh
existentially threatening as what Trump
is threatening of course not so but
generally he's doing fine and he's got a
lot more done substantially
legislatively I mean he got us out of
Afghanistan which yeah did he stick the
landing on it no but a lot of that was
because Trump organized that before he
even got there with his stupid it will
get out by this date and he only left
2500 troops there he left him a horrible
hand so it's not a terrible idea to say
that and of course the Democrats never
do because they're just so afraid oh
they'll just say we're using excuses
it's a reasonable excuse It's a real
excuse having said that they could have
done it better but at least we did it
and we should have done it and he
actually got the ball rolling on climate
change in a big way that nobody's been
able to do before he'd steered most of
this big money we're spending towards
stuff they're all really climate change
bills and nobody did that and he got
infrastructure going and you know he's
he's an old school kind of guy is he
perfect of course not but he's getting
the job done and we're back to normal
it's not Insanity he's not you know poop
tweeting and having feuds with Bette
Midler and you know throwing towels at
people I mean it's just it's a lot who's
been for you the greatest American
president of them all well certainly the
one I've seen in my lifetime I mean it
would be Obama I mean didn't see George
Washington but you know he's still the
greatest in my view because there would
be no country without him and he made
some incredible decisions like how he
won the war which most generals could
not have won that war saying he would
not be a king refusing the crown and
saying no we have to have a peaceful
transfer of power I do think you giving
up
while King was a massive strategic error
I'm sure you just for the record
um but Obama you know as far as modern
presidents and no one can compare first
of all because what he did he came in
right at a moment of incredible economic
crisis that a lot of other guys would
have crashed we would be in a depression
now
and you know no drama Obama boy you know
he just kept it his eye on the ball and
by the way we didn't even lose money
does he does the American first black
president right that was a very hardest
thing I mean I always said and he had to
be the Jackie Robinson of anyway Jackie
Robinson in the sense of you can't take
the bait they're going to say horrible
things you just got to keep your eye in
the ball amazing discipline this guy I
agree with that does he remember Can
Dream still exist
do you think yeah in fact that's maybe
the one thing that does exist that we
still have going for us because we've
lost so much but I talked about this all
the time
um
especially with people who have come to
this country on purpose you know and not
from countries that uh are places you'd
think where people would want to leave
like your country people come here on
purpose I know people from France in
Germany and Canada and I think what they
would say is yes America has a great
flaw in that we don't take care of the
losers quite as well as socialist
countries you know if you fall behind
it's kind of like well see you wouldn't
want to be you but what America does
have is still the sense of possibility
you absolutely can reinvent yourself
tomorrow
and be whatever you want you can make
your future here you can make your way
and you can go as high as as high as you
can they don't cut down the tall trees
as a Canadian friend of mine once said
um so in that sense there is still the
American dream now how available is that
to everybody
that's a good question
well it says the next tonight Bill Mars
well
tough verdict
gruesome too
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no what
are you every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7 pm join me just do it well
that one too
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
foreign
politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
well coming up from our brand new studio
on The Talk Harry and Williams set to
give each other the cold shoulder at the
coronation where she soon acts
investigated over his wife's shares in a
childcare agency that could benefit from
the budget and the Bracken beacons is
renamed in response to climate change
Peak woke or what that's at nine
[Music]
welcome back uh next tonight Bill Miles
made no secret of his disdain for the
concept of monarchy but will he be
watching the coronation and what do
Americans really make of the Harry and
Megan circus
the coronation is coming up and I know
you're probably trying to suppress your
wild excitement okay will you be
watching no of course not it's not my
country and if you care about the royal
family of course not it's an
inaccuritism and it's I I said there's
two people who are Royals to their face
I'm not going to call you your highness
I said that to Queen nor really
absolutely I said it's ridiculous that
one human being this is something
liberals especially should believe that
you don't call another human being your
highness are you kidding me no
[Laughter]
and uh you know although I do personally
I like Charles I always thought he was a
smart guy he had some really good issues
you know I thought they made fun of him
you know he had gave him some ammunition
for that but no public person doesn't
but
um you know why why even have this and I
know there are reasons enjoy it what
have you been hanging out with Megan and
Harry's since they've been in California
no I don't know them
what do you think of them I I admire
Harry for going to Afghanistan anybody
who's had who's had military service I
can only criticize so much because I
haven't and there's nothing that
compares to military service
um but
they're ridiculous after that they're
just they want it both ways you know you
can't be uh these people were so mean to
us and and poor us and we don't want all
this attention and then let me let me
write a book about how much we don't
want attention a little South Park we
want our privacy yeah I mean that sums
it up really they just strike me as
creatures of that generation you know
you're just fragile you know just take
it Take a Hint from the Queen the
recently departed never complain never
explain and rarely be heard speaking in
public you're complaining about how your
hard life and you're so privileged it's
just so weird it's ridiculous I totally
agree well you've had an extraordinary
life how long do you think you can keep
doing this decades forever do you think
you'll ever want to stop I have a
contract for a billion years like like
in Scientology I would watch you for it
as long as you want to do it but I I
don't know I mean the fact that I've
done it for 30 years is just ridiculous
but I feel in no way diminished you
enjoy it as much
because I'm you know you get better at
what if you do something for 30 years I
mean you better get better you know at a
certain point you know same thing with
Biden
um you know yes age could actually have
an effect on how you're doing but that's
I I would be the first one to tell you
if it did and plainly it's not well the
audience I want you every week and I
have to say I think right now you are
probably the most important I can tell
me because well thank you you are the
voice of Common Sense amid all the
insanity and also basically you're on
their side the loops it's like come on
stop being so mad no I think you're a
great voice too and also of Common Sense
and there's lots of it and by the way
none of us are what anyone 10 years ago
would even begin to call a conservative
you know we're not conservatives I mean
you go down the line about what we
believe and how we live our life it's
not we're not out there shooting Bud
Lights and I will not bend the knee and
just go along with the nonsense that's
what's so annoying about them the most
well they like insist that you go along
with their nonsense and their insanity
and their fragility or else you're
thrown outside the group and and you're
excommunicated from liberal and no
you're not the liberal I'm I haven't
changed you invented a whole new thing
called wokism which used to have a much
more valid meaning it's actually a form
of fascism the way they go about it the
way they without the extreme violence
but the ideology that you will conform
yes to our narrow worldview and if you
don't we're going to really do bad stuff
to you yeah that's a fascist mentality
it's it's it's the cry bullies of that
generation as I said raised wrong
so they think when someone disagrees
with them it's a hate crime and it's
violence and it's unacceptable and it's
just got to stop you don't get your
teenagers under control yeah I
completely that's my message Bill it's a
great message keep battling I'm with you
thank you all right
what a fantastic interview and what a
refreshing attitude wasn't it just don't
tolerate the woke Insanity they can be
mad
we've seen examples on the show tonight
of utter Madness teachers being made to
apologize to kids who don't want to be
called girls at a girls school that's
bad
fat people wanting free seats on planes
that's mad
and it's all fragile it's all pathetic
it's all attention seeking and we don't
have to go along with it stand up world
fight Bank just say no be more like Bill
Maher that's it from me good to be back
in our wonderful new studio whatever
you're doing Keep It Uncensored I keep
the wokies away good night
[Music]
thank you
foreign
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy
speechwriters here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it for
that one too
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about